das ändert alles eine japanische zeitung
ließ einen tesla modell 3 komplett
zerlegen und machte eine unglaubliche
entdeckung die zentrale steuereinheit
des wagens scheint eine absolute
geheimwaffe des autobauers zu sein an
die kein anderer autobauer heran kommt
die elektronik ist der andere hersteller
um jahre voraus und die konkurrenz gibt
selber zu dass sie keine chance hätte so
etwas aktuell selber hinzugekommen und
tesla plant schon den nächsten schritt
klicks und täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und activity
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen mengenmäßig
sind die großen etablierten
automobilkonzerne wie vw oder toyota
tesla um längen voraus sie verkaufen
rund zehn millionen autos pro jahr
während der e auto pionier zuletzt knapp
400.000 autos in einem jahr verkauft
hatte
bei einem ist der us-autobauer den
anderen aber weit voraus bei der
technologie die bereitet der konkurrenz
kopfzerbrechen und das völlig zu recht
wie die japanische zeitung nikkei jetzt
aufdeckte die zeitung hat nämlich
einfach einen tesla modell 3 in all
seine einzelteile zerlegt und ist bei
der steuereinheit über eine unglaubliche
entdeckung gestolpert die zentrale
steuereinheit namens full self driving
computer wurde im frühjahr letzten
jahres auf den markt gebracht und wird
in den neuen modell 3s und iks verbaut
sie enthält zwei maßangefertigte 260
quadratmillimeter chips für künstliche
intelligenz die neben dem
fahrassistenten auch das infotainment
system steuern und die bezeichnung
sollte man sich noch mal auf der zunge
zergehen lassen
self driving computer computer für
uneingeschränktes autonomes fahren
wir können uns also an einem finger
ausrechnen was tesla mit dem nächsten
update machen wird und der punkt ist das
modul ist von tesla selbst entwickelt
worden und offensichtlich so intelligent
dass es denen anderer hersteller um
jahre voraus ist ein ingenieur eines
japanischen autohersteller sagte nachdem
der computer untersucht wurde
selbstzitat wir können das nicht
hinbekommen bei der elektronik hat tesla
offensichtlich einen vorsprung von
ganzen sechs jahren
und insider in der industrie erwarten
dass andere automobilhersteller
frühestens 2025 eine solche elektronik
plattform entwickeln und einsetzen
können so eine plattform mit einem
starken zentralen computer gilt als das
zentrale element für selbstfahrende
fahrzeuge auch peter friedl von der
technologie und innovationsberatung
altran ist überzeugt dass der
kalifornische hersteller einen großen
technologischen vorsprung habe genau
beziffern möchte er ihn aber nicht in
den herkömmlichen alten autos hat jede
funktions gruppe ein eigenes steuergerät
damit diese unabhängig voneinander und
dadurch von verschiedenen zuliefern
entwickelt werden können je komplexer
die modelle werden desto mehr
steuergeräte brauchen sie auch das
können bei einem auto in der oberklasse
schon mal zwischen 80 und 100 stück
seien alle von verschiedenen herstellern
nicht zum bei tesla
zum einen gibt es nur eine steuereinheit
und zum anderen sind bei tesla die
meisten teile im model 3 ausschließlich
selbst entwickelt damit liegt auch die
kontrolle über die entwicklung der
schlüsseltechnologien im auto bei tesla
selbst und ist völlig unabhängig von
zulieferketten
die sind bei den klassischen
autoherstellern wohl auch die ursache
dafür dass sie so hinterherhinken laut
christian senger mitglied des vw
markenvorstand für das ressort digital
kn services stecken durch den einsatz
von technologien dritter in einem
typischen premiumfahrzeug von vw zehn
millionen zeilen code die sich auf 70
steuergeräte verteilen diese laufen
wiederum auf acht verschiedenen
betriebssystemen dadurch sei es
unmöglich für jede funktion des systems
sogenannte over der updates einspielen
zu können was tesla mit seiner eigenen
software schafft für den autobesitzer
ist es also ein riesenvorteil dass die
tesla autos von der software ausgedacht
werden updates müssen nicht zwingend
kabelgebunden in einer werkstatt
durchgeführt werden und over the air
updates sind definitiv die zukunft der
smarten fahrzeuge dass sie hinterher
hinken ist den großen automobilkonzern
durchaus bewusst vw chef herbert diess
sagte im januar selbstzitat die zeit
klassischer automobilhersteller ist
vorbei wen plant deshalb sich zu einem
digitalen konzern umzustrukturieren
um diesen bremsen klotz am bein
loszuwerden der wolfsburger autokonzern
baut dafür eine große abteilung mit
eigenen software experten auf
bis 2025 sollen sich mehr als 10.000
expertinnen um die software kümmern noch
in diesem jahr sollen dazu 2500
beschäftigte in dem bereich eingestellt
werden während die klassischen autobauer
technologisch noch von ihren zulieferern
abhängig sind tüftelt tesla fleißig
weiter und das ist für die alten
autohersteller ein riesenproblem jeder
und jede die einen tesla probe fährt und
dann ein elektroauto eines
traditionellen autoherstellers wird
merken dass tesla den anderen fahrzeugen
haushoch überlegen ist infotainment
navigation reichweiten berechnung
supercharger antrieb autopilot und und
und die kalifornische firma hatte
volkswagen im januar erstmals beim
börsenwert überholt und arbeitet eigenen
angaben zufolge schon am nächsten großen
chip laut tesla chef elon musk soll der
noch mal drei mal leistungsstärker
werden als der aktuelle
es wird also schwierig für die
etablierten konzerne die aufholjagd im
aufstrebenden markt der voll vernetzten
elektroautos noch erfolgreich zu
schaffen
allen masc geheime batterie revolution
bei tesla anklicken anschauen und klicks
und science fiction ja kanal mitglied
werden am besten damit könnte er unser
projekt mit einem kleinen beitragen
unterstützen und ihr bekommt unsere
videos vor allen anderen als exklusiven
link nur für kanal mitglieder
ich bedanke mich schon mal im voraus für
euren support bis dann bleibt dran